[Musique]
c'est une convention signée entre le
département de La Réunion et la saphir
qui ensemble s'engage au déploiement du
plan à million d'armes la safirme est à
disposition une centaine de sites sur
lesquels seront plantés des plantes
endémiques et indigènes de la Réunion
comme ici à Saint-Paul sur le site de
mon reposier à thé mais c'est un honneur
et surtout une responsabilité pour nous
de continuer à planter des arbres à
protéger cette nature et à donner à nos
jeunes enfants réunionnais
des possibilités de vivre sur une île
toujours aussi verte et protégée il y a
des bois de nef sachant que les bois de
Saint-Paul
nanas
et bien d'autres divers plans
ce sont des élèves du lycée agricole de
Saint-Paul qui ont cultivé cette
microforée d'une trentaine d'espèces
représentatives du milieu 850 plans ont
été ici mis en terre et 300 autres sur
le site de vilel à chaque fois qu'il y a
un site où il y a une station de
refoulement ou une station de pompage
nous allons embellir ses cours avec ces
plantations là saphir s'engage à planter
5000 espèces par an durant ces quatre
prochaines années avec le soutien bien
sûr du Conservatoire Botanique des
mascarins ou encore avec la SPL Eden qui
vont nous fournir pour fournir en arbre
donc en espèces pour embellir nos sites
depuis son lancement par le Département
le plan 1 million d'arbres voit déjà
pousser plus de 160 000 espèces
endémiques et indigènes sur tout le
territoire
[Musique]